hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in politics book 1 Aristotle is going to
make a very fundamental distinction
between four different types of
rulership he thinks that these are not
only distinguishable from each other so
that we ought to keep this distinction
in mind but he also thinks in point of
fact that many people tend to mix these
up or to have confused and mistaken
understandings about these including in
some cases entire cultures entire
people's so this is an incredibly
important distinction with many
implications both for the politics as a
whole and also for Aristotle's ethics so
it's very important to you know make
this distinction early on in the book
and to follow out what some of these
implications are first before we do that
though let's look at the actual passage
it's very short where he brings us up he
tells us that people are mistaken who
think that the the nature or the
structure however you want to put it of
these four different sorts of rulership
and the people associated with them are
the same we have political rule the
politico in' and that would be run by
somebody who we translate sometimes a
statesman or state's person this is a
type of rulership in which citizens are
engaged with each other and either vote
somebody into office or choose them by
Lots power is being exercised over
somebody who is recognized as in other
respects being one's equal then we have
monarchic own rule and there's different
kinds of monarchies that Aristotle will
discuss and we could even think of you
know some other degenerate forms of
monarchy you know that we discussed as
as tyranny as approximating this boss
ali khan although in general we want to
think of the good form of monarchy and
then we have what we can translate as
household rule this would be the
head of the family or head of a entire
larger household that is hueco no Mekong
and then we have masterly rule the sort
of thing that involves actual slavery
the dis faulty continent and what
there's a word that we get despot from
so you can imagine that this is not
quite the same thing as monarchical rule
and he tells us that those who think
that these are all the same are
fundamentally mistaken now who might be
people who think that these at least in
part or even in whole are all the same
sort of power structure anybody who
thinks that all power by its very nature
is despotic involves something like
slavery they would fit in with this and
in his own time Aristotle criticizes the
people who he calls the barbarians which
would include all non Greeks and even
perhaps some of the Greeks for Aristotle
quite frankly because they don't
recognize the fundamental difference
between as he says a little bit you know
inaccurately women and slaves so the
relation between husband and wife is for
them according to Aristotle the same
thing as a relationship between master
and slave the same sort of power is
being exerted the same structure of
relationship the same type of top-down
rule is being imposed and Aristotle says
we'll see this is an example of how the
barbarians actually get things wrong
they don't real he doesn't say that
women are on the same level as men but
he does think that it has to be a
different kind of rulership that would
fit more into household rule or
depending on who the the woman is and
who the husband is it could even be sort
of like an analogue to political rule
but it's mostly gonna fit into this
household rule and he talks about a few
other ways in which people often get
this mixed up he says that
some people think that the difference
between these various forms of rulership
or authority is one of greater and
smaller numbers so as we move from say
the master/slave relationship or from
the household relationship which are on
a lower level up to the political level
where we have an entire people or a
political community underneath one
person several people whoever is in
charge they think of this as just you
know the the household writ large or the
master/slave relationship writ large so
that everybody becomes slaves of the
monarch or we're all part of this is a
very common phrase here over in America
we're all part of one big family
Aristotle would say no no the political
community is not a family the family
belongs down here and he would say the
political community definitely should
not be structured in the same way as the
relation between master and slave is
these are fundamental mistakes in his
view so he says that as to the statesman
or the political ruler and the royal
ruler they think that one who governs as
the sole head is royal and one who while
the government follows the principles of
the science of royalty takes turns to
govern and be governed is a statesman
and they says that's not actually true
you could in fact have a monarch a
single ruler but it could be political
rule think about you know the office of
the president here in the United States
as the head of state granted there's
many other things going on as well but
as the head of state they are something
like the Aristotelian monarch but they
are elected it is political rule
likewise just having a number of people
doesn't necessarily make it political
rule so there's a few other things that
he says about this a little bit further
in politics book 2 he says we can use
this this mode of parsing these
relationships out to understand the
relationship between people and also
parts of our own psyche or soul or
personality if you like so he says in
studying human beings we must consider a
person who's in the best possible
condition in regard to both body and
soul and if we do that what we're going
to see is that the body is ruled by the
soul if things are the other way around
then the soul rules the body for
instance people who are driven by
addictions or who have moral vices or
anything along or people who are lack
self-control anything along those lines
would be problematic because the body is
in charge so he says the human being is
a living creature and we can discern in
there the rule both of Master and States
person how so says the soul rules the
body with the sway of a master in an
ideal circumstance that should be the
relationship between the soul and the
body according to Aristotle the soul
commands the body obeys the body doesn't
get to ask questions the body doesn't
get to make exceptions the body is not
part of the deliberative process the
soul decides and the body has to obey
now you can say what's the penalty if
the body doesn't obey and that's a
little bit of a problem with the analogy
there with slavery of course if you
don't obey you you incur some sort of
usually bodily circumstances that are
going to be quite horrific and arbitrary
but notice here that Aristotle is saying
there are some cases in which this sort
of seemingly arbitrary despotic use of
power is in fact what is called for
we're going to see that not all slavery
is actually just slavery according to
Aristotle but that's a
topic what about the parts of the soul
Aristotle thinks that we have a higher
and lower part of the soul there's a
little bit more to his anthropology than
that but that's enough for right now how
does the higher part of the soul relate
itself to the lower part of the soul
does it rule despotic lis or should it
rule in a different way he says that the
intelligence the mind the intellect
rules the appetites the realm of the
desires and emotions with a
constitutional or political rule or with
a royal rule so these types of rule are
not just about whether it applies to a
whole political community it's about the
structure the way in which power is
being exercised and used so let's think
about this for a moment as we wrap this
up despotic rule slavery rule very easy
to understand some people that's all
they view power as or authority as
somebody commands somebody obeys if they
don't obey they get punished that's a
very low-level kind of relation it's
suitable for cases where you really
can't reason with the thing that is
being rule or the person who is being
ruled you can't reason with your body
you also can't reason with a computer
and the parts of the computer can't
reason with each other this is why you
could think of the parts of the computer
is in a master/slave relation to each
other most human beings you can in fact
reason with and so different kinds of
relations are required household rule
the economic a oriented toward some
common good there is an imbalance in an
in power but it's closer than the
master/slave relationship there's also
the possibility that at least
some people in the household similarly
with the political rule that people will
step into new roles those who are ruled
will eventually become rulers as a
matter of fact one of the key things
that Aristotle says both about the
household and about political rule he
really stresses this with political
arrangements is that in order to be able
to rule effectively you have to have
learned how to obey and be ruled that's
part of the process in the case of
monarchy coal rule ideally it is being
carried out for the good of all involved
in the community when that's not the
case when monarchic elizabe incurring
out for the good of the ruler or perhaps
his or her friends and family then it
actually starts to slide into a
relationship of despotism it quits being
monarch achill and it becomes tyrannical
instead which is essentially treating
everybody as if they're slaves
political rule is between people who are
acknowledged as equals all of whom are
to at least some degree rational capable
of deliberation perhaps together perhaps
on their own and they take turns
according to some sort of Constitution
some sort of arrangement something that
allows them to say this is actually a
fear use of power now we could think
about all sorts of other cases and see
if we can apply Aristotle's view point
to them think about for example a
workplace is a workplace more like
master/slave relations more like a
household more like monarchic alike
political rule it really depends on the
workplace doesn't it a coop for example
would be political rule a terrible
workplace to be in would be masterly
rule
a family business may in fact be part of
household rule and may include other
people who somehow come into the family
as well it may also be monarchic old
rule think about when you have a large
corporation with a Board of Directors
and a CEO at the top and all sorts of
layers of hierarchy so each of these
would have its own demands and its own
way of structuring power and relations
and what people can expect in the
framework of these you know at a
political rule you can expect a lot more
than you can in despotic rule likewise
household rule and in relation to
despotic rule so it's very important to
get this distinction down when going
into Aristotle's politics but it also
has some very important implications for
Aristotle's ethics as well
you